malgré un bond important du nombre de
cas le premier souvenez de l'entendre
mesdames et messieurs se dit confiant
parce que le taux d'hospitalisation
étant de choc de ce qu'on croyait de ce
qu'on avait prévu
dr karl weiss président de l'association
des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
est avec nous dr weiss bonsoir vous est
de cet avis aussi on va voir les
chiffres ensemble mais on est pour
l'instant sous contrôle parce que on a
peut-être moins de gens que l'on croyait
que l'on craignait qu'ils se rendent à
l'hôpital
il faut être très prudent régler chif
vous avez vu avant-hier on a eu des pas
très bons chiffres hier on a eu les
meilleurs chiffres
aujourd'hui on n'a pas des bombes des
très bons chiffres donc en réalité il va
falloir voir ça pas sur une journée mais
il faut voir ça sur des semaines et des
tendances
donc il faut voir et tendances l'autre
se mesure par semaine parce que ça
dépend beaucoup de la quantité de tests
qui est sorti et de tous les jours donc
pour l faut faire attention il faut
quand même regarder ce sont les chiffres
j'appellerai lourd c'est à dire le taux
d'hospitalisation qui tourne autour de 6
points 8 7% et le nombre de patients en
soins intensifs et pour l'instant autour
de deux points 5 3% dont est encore
relativement bas mais malheureusement la
ddc mais on n'est certainement pas dans
la situation de notre pays
donc il ya des bonnes nouvelles mais les
chiffres sont vraiment très tôt pour
pouvoir tirer de grandes conclusions il
ne pense qu'il va falloir attendre au
moins la prochaine semaine pour savoir
où est-ce qu'on soit exactement la
semaine et beaucoup le disent
et vous êtes de cet avis donc la semaine
qui s'en vient va être très importante
pour voir la lure du reste de la courbe
tout à fait donc leur falloir qu'on voit
ou est ce qu'on s'en va dans la course
cette semaine et la semaine prochaine
les deux prochaines semaines on est
vraiment critique parce que là on va
enlever tout ce qui touche les voyages
les retours etc
on va voir la transmission locale
quelques voix là et s'il est si les gens
sont disciplinés en fait c'est ce qu'on
va voir exactement on va voir maintenant
est-ce que les gens sont disciplinés et
surtout ce qu'on a fait tout ce qu'on
fait un impact sur cette courbe lie
commence maintenant à avoir un impact en
diminuant ce qu'on peut avoir comme
cours et peut-être qu'à ce moment là si
dans deux semaines on est à des chiffres
qui sont on voit que le système va tenir
ce sera tant mieux pour nous vous
compreniez on est dans la phase à chaud
c'est à dire on est dans le rang mais
dans une phase défensive par rapport à
ce virus là on n'a pas de médicaments on
a pas de vaccin on doit absorber le choc
on doit à tenir nos lignes si vous
voulez mais préparez un jour notre notre
offensive est donc là on est dans
vraiment cette phase-là d'absorber le
choc et de comprendre que ça sera long
parce que il y avait ça aujourd'hui qui
transparaissent est clairement dans le
point de presse et et dans l'avis de
tous les experts c'est que dans deux
semaines c'est pas terminer cette
histoire là soyons clairs non non c'est
sûr s'il ya quelqu'un qui pense que dans
deux semaines les vacances sont finies
puis tout va revenir à la normale pas du
tout non non on en a pour longtemps
certainement et de façon réaliste là
c'est sûr que à l'animé on sera
peut-être dans une page un peu plus
quand ils on verra bien mais c'est sûr
que jusqu'au moins le mois d'avril va
être comme a été dès la dernière semaine
en termes de virer confinement bon dr
weiss est très claire et au moins on
ne tourne pas autour du pot je vous
présente là des questions du public
ça revient beaucoup y at il une façon de
renforcer notre système immunitaire
vous avez parlé de cette guerre et de
l'ennemi qui arrive à ce qu'on peut
mieux se préparer
préparer notre corps non ben oui vous
pouvez bien manger bien dormir bien vous
reposer pas vous stressé tout ça ça
favorise les systèmes immunitaires
ça veut pas dire que le système
immunitaire va se défendre de façon
adéquate mais au moins vous allez il n'y
a pas de médicaments miracles où il est
le système immunitaire des actes et la
question quand il ya un an forme de
facteurs qu'on peut faire pour avoir une
hygiène de vie et soeurs est ce que
toutes les personnes combattent le virus
à la même vitesse d'où le 14 jours ça
c'est intéressant parce qu'on répète le
14 jours comme un mantra là mais est-ce
que chez certaines personnes ça pourrait
être plus long et donc plus rapides
oui bien sûr mais il faut dire que 14
jours c'est la phase aiguë de la maladie
donc les gens qui ont été très malade
des fois ça va leur prendre trois quatre
cinq semaines pour récupérer des gens
qui auront peut-être été incubés aux
soins intensifs par contre à l'opposé
des gens qui vont pas être très mal
ils vont avoir des symptômes pendant
quelques heures et une drôle de question
mais je vous la pose lâche pas sûr de la
comprendre totalement mais pourrait-on
combattre la caunette 19 avec un autre
virus
bon j'imagine la grippe la personne fait
référence à la grippe dont il existe
déjà un vaccin
nous sommes vraiment alors vous savez il
ya des gens qui ont réussi dire c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'interférence des virus
c'est-à-dire si vous avez des virus ça
empêcherait un autre virus de 2,2 vous
l'envahir simple d'ascq
c'est ça alors c'est une compétition
antivirus lequel va gagner l'un par
rapport à l'eau il ya des gens qui ont
pensé de faire ça même dans certains
pays en chine entre autres sa veille à
des virus des d'autres virus du coronado
lyonnaise s'appelle l'os et 43 qui est
un virus corona mais gentil on va dire
qu'il donne des rues en se disant si
vous attrapez coc 43 vous faites un
rhume peut-être que vous aurez pas
l'autre parce que le gentil corona y
laissera pas l'autre entraîneur c'est
bon ça alors mais c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche mais dans le fond c'est comme
ça
est ce que certains pays développe des
tests de diagnostic rapide à faire à la
maison
ce genre de test pourrait-il être utile
ici tout à fait alors ça va venir
forcément il ya des compagnies qui
développe sa des tests rapides
peut-être pas à faire à la maison tant
on n'est pas rendu là mais certainement
des tests rapides ils pourront être fait
dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux donc les gens
se présenter à l'urgence
l'apathie litres et la gestion des cas
bon je passe à la question 6 on attend
de plus en plus parler des résultats
surprenants et l'on va pas le temps
d'expliquer docteur de la chloroquine
dans le traitement de la cop et 19
qu'en est il alors là il ya des sources
partout il ya ce médecin français on en
a parlé souvent ça là là là les
autorités aux etats-unis ont accepté que
ce soit testé à plus grande échelle sur
l'être humain alors est ce que c'est une
voie prometteuse oui ou non ont
peut-être moins je vous dirai peut-être
peut-être peut-être la réalité c'est que
l'hydroxyde européenne et le plafond il
n'est pas une cure pour ce virus là donc
c'est pas un médicament qui va guérir
l'infection par le comique 19 comme par
exemple des médicaments pour l'influenza
et 10 actuellement
c'est une molécule qui souvent a par
ailleurs il associe à une autre molécule
qui s'appelle un titre aux meetings et
des propriétés anti inflammatoires au
niveau du poumon et qu'on utilise pour
des conditions pulmonaire et les deux
ensembles ont démontré qu'il y avait
peut-être une diminution de la charge
virale mais il ya énormément toujours
controversée par rapport à ça
l'engouement pour cette molécule c'est
un engouement un petit peu l'humain
pascal dati a rien d'autre
alors comme les gens se disent qu'ils à
rien d'autre ils se disent on va
utiliser ça comme je l ai déjà dit ça me
rappelle l'histoire de l'art était au
début de l'époque du vih quand on avait
donné de l'ase était à quelques patients
qui en avait dit monté de 5 milliards de
façon drastique
on a peut être trouvé un tueur pour le
vih alors on était très loin de saint et
l'histoire a prouvé le contraire
alors il y as peut-être un effet
bénéfique peut-être il va falloir le
prouver mais ce qui va falloir faire il
va falloir avoir des études soient
faites par des équipes qui soit
différente de l'équipe
guerra ou en france pour montrer qu'on
est capable de reproduire les mêmes
choses et que ça vient de la mairie
voilà et puis johnson & johnson on
apprenait aujourd'hui on se laisse là
dessus d'octobre a annoncé qu'ils vont
même construire une usine pour fabriquer
un vaccin là je parle d'un vaccin non
pas d'un médicament
cet automne qui seraient testées il
serait testée cet automne sur des êtres
humains et que il s'engage à ne pas
faire de profit si jamais ça fonctionne
est ce que ça vous fait est ce que ça
vous donne d'espoir entre nantes
ben oui si une compagnie trouver un
vaccin qui est efficace et sécuritaire
je pense que ça va donner de l'espoir
alors on met tous en attente de sa 6 ème
compagnie qui arrive à le faire très
rapidement ben tant mieux surtout que
probablement qu'à l'automne qui s'en
vient on devrait avoir une stratégie
haut par rapport au corps en un virus
qui sera probablement encore présent
mais peut-être sous d'autres formes et à
d'autres niveaux donc si on a des
accents ce moment là très bien comment
sinon ça va de temps voilà santé vous
vous êtes dans un hôpital qui est
chargée aussi est-ce que commence la
première ligne comment se porte la
première ligne écoutez le
c'est vrai que les équipes sont très
fatigués les gens sont les gens donnent
énormément d'énergie
c'est un combat continue je pense que
mais les gens sont courageux sont très
bien leur travail
et puis les gens sont là c'est un choix
d'être dans les carrières de la santé
alors c'est là où je pense que les gens
vont faire ce qu'ils voulaient faire
durant leur vie mais mais nous on peut
faire une partie
la population peut faire une autre
partie c'est d'écouter les grandes les
comptines pour leur a donné voilà très
bien dit merci docteur continue avec
plaisir au revoir merci bonsoir